ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BACKER FORTRESS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTEZ THE VALLEY DODD
THEY'RE AWESOME EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG WEST
SO- TADO JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED
LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE MELENDEZ
MEN. NEWMAN NIELSEN A CHAU BOTH
PAM PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNE TURN NUMBER WHITE HOUSE
SKI WIENER WILK. MEMBERS OF A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RIGHTS. WILL BE. WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR PAN AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING AND WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR STERN- PAN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT TODAY WE
PRAY FROM PSALM ONE OH THREE.
WHAT'S THE LORD OH MY SOUL AND
ALL THAT IS WITHIN ME. BLESS
GOD'S HOLY NAME. YES THE LORD OH
MY SOUL REMEMBER ALL GODS
BENEFITS. IT IS GOD WHO HEALS
ARE ILLS REDEEMS OUR LIFE FROM
THE PIT. BROWN'S US WITH LOVE
AND COMPASSION AND FILLS US WITH
ALL GOOD THINGS. FIRST THE
HEAVENS ARE HIGH ABOVE THE EARTH
SO ENORMOUS IS GOD'S MERCY. AND
AS FAR AS THE EAST IS FROM THE
WEST SO FAR FROM US THIS GOD
MOVE OUR FAILURES. PARENTS HAVE
COMPASSION ON THEIR CHILDREN SO
DIVINE COMPASSION THIS SHOWER ON
ALL OF US. IN ALL OUR
EXPERIENCES LET US PRAY. THE
LORD ON. EXAMINE THE CULTURALLY. IT IS. LAW THANK YOU MEMBERS
WILL START WITH MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. MISTER
PRESIDENT I'M DIFFERENT DIRECTED
TO INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ON THIS DAY
PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE- PARKER CHIEF CLERK
OF THE ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU
BARTRAM COMMITTEE WILL BE THE-
MISTER PRESIDENT I'M DIRECTED TO
INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED SENATE
BILL FIVE OH FOUR AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
HONORABLE BODY TO CONCURRENCE AT
AMENDMENTS THE PARKER CHIEF
CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY ABOVE THE
ORDER TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
FILE. THANK YOU REPORTER
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. THE
FOLLOWING BILL REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON RULES SB. FIVE OH
FOUR. MOTIONS TO APPROVE- THE
SENATE JOURNAL WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNAL FOR THE WEEK
OF MARCH TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. NOW MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. WE HAVE SENATE
SECOND READING I MEAN OUR SECOND
READING FILE WE HAVE. NINE ITEMS
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL NINE THIRTY NINE EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHT
SIXTY FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHT
EIGHTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
NINE TWENTY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHT NINETY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS EIGHT FORTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHT SIXTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS AND SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU NOW.
MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
FIRST UP. IS FILE ITEM THIRTEEN.
CENTER EGGMAN ARE YOU PREPARED.
HE IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR EGGMAN RELATIVE
TO SOCIAL WORK MONTH INTERREGNUM
THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE THIS MORNING I RISE
THIS AFTERNOON I RISE TO PRESENT
S. R. SIXTY NINE RECOGNIZING
MARCH A SOCIAL WORKER MONTH IT
IS ALSO ALWAYS FITTING I THINK
TO DO THIS ON WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH AS MANY OF THOSE IN THE
PROFESSION. ARE WOMEN ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE A GROWING NUMBER OF MEN
ALSO IN THE PROFESSION I WOULD
HAVE BEEN A COUPLE REALLY TOUGH
YEARS FOR SOCIAL WORKERS ACROSS
IF YOU WORK IN A HOSPITAL. OR
YOU WORK IN A SCHOOL OR YOU WORK
IN A- URGENCY ROOM OR A PRISON
OR ANYWHERE WHERE THERE ARE
PEOPLE LIVING TOGETHER. YOU HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. ONE OF MY FRIENDS
A SOCIAL WORKER UP IN A
PLACERVILLE AND SPENT. THE LAST
TWO YEARS BASICALLY TALKING-
SINGLE BY FOR PEOPLE TO THEIR
FAMILIES. WITH AN IPAD DAY IN
AND DAY OUT OF THOSE KIND OF
THINGS WHERE ON A PEOPLE- BUT WE
ARE EVERYWHERE MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICS HOSPITALS HOSPICE
ADOPTION AGENCIES NONPROFITS.
COURTS AND OF COURSE EVEN HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE- AND YOU'VE
ALL HEARD ME TALK ABOUT THIS
DESPITE HAVING SPECIALIZED
TRAINING- WE STILL DO NOT HAVE
TITLE PROTECTION AND ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS TIME WE'RE CALLING
FOR MORE MORE. SOCIAL WORKERS TO
BE INTEGRATED INTO OUR- FIRST
RESPONDERS AND PUBLIC SAFETY I
THINK IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT AT
SOME POINT WE- WE TAKE THE FINAL
STEP OF DOING KIND OF PROTECTION
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS SO. IF OR TO
CALL YOURSELF A SOCIAL CREE
WOULD HAVE A DEGREE. IN THE
PROFESSION EVEN THOUGH WE
ACKNOWLEDGE PEOPLE LIKE OUR- OUR
OWN CENTER PAT BATES WHO WORKS
AS A SOCIAL WORKER- WAY BACK
WHEN SHE WAS A YOUNG MOM. BUT
BEFORE MSW PROGRAMS WERE
AVAILABLE TO ALL WE DON'T
DISCOUNT WHAT SHE DID BUT AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE TO PROFESSIONAL
LIES THE DEGREE- WE THINK TOTAL
PROTECTION IS IMPORTANT- AND SO.
FOR THAT AND FOR MANY OTHER
REASONS- I ASK THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE. SOCIAL WORKERS
TODAY EVERY DAY BUT ESPECIALLY A
KNOWLEDGE MARS MARCH A SOCIAL
WORKER MONTH AND I ASK FOR YOUR
BY VOTE ON SR SIXTY NINE. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE FILE ITEM THIRTEEN ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HEARING SEEN ON MOUNT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS. BATES I
BAKER. I PORCHES I BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO. CORTESE I DALY AYE
DODD I TORONTO. EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG AYE WESA AYE HURTADO
AYE JONES. I KAMLAGER I LAYERED
AYE LEYVA AYE MON AYE WIRE AYE
MELENDEZ AYE MIN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN AYE TELEVOTE AYE PAN I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M
BURKE WHITE HOUSESKI AYE WIENER
AYE WILK. I. FIVE THIRTY SIX.
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW MEMBERS REMOVE ON A FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN BY SENATOR LAMAR
OWN. HE'S PREPARED BROWN
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION NINE BY SENATOR
LIMON RELATIVE TO THE NON
RESIDENT TUITION EXEMPTION AND
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS CITADEL
MALL THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT S. J. R. NINE
TO RECOGNIZE OCTOBER TWELFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT THE
TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ENACTMENT OF EIGHTY FIVE FORTY.
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY HAS MADE
COLLEGE ACCESSIBLE FOR COUNTLESS
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS BY MAKING
THEM ELIGIBLE FOR IN STATE
TUITION. UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
HAVE HISTORICALLY FACED BARRIERS
THAT RESTRICT ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND THAT LIMIT THEIR
ABILITY TO WORK OR CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES. AB FIVE
FORTY HAS PROVIDED A PATHWAY FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TO ACCESS
AFFORDABLE HIGHER EDUCATION AND
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACHIEVE THEIR
HIGHEST POTENTIAL. STR NINE
CALLS ON CONGRESS TO PASS THE
AMERICAN FAMILIES PLAN AND
PROVIDE FINANCIAL RESOURCES FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS THROUGH
THE BUDGET RECONCILIATION
PROCESS. AND TO ADOPT
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
I AM PROUD TO HAVE WORKED WITH
MANY EIGHTY FIVE FORTY STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND SEE HOW MUCH
THEY CONTRIBUTE TO OUR LOCAL
ECONOMY AND WHAT A COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY DOES FOR THEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION A BIT
ON THE SIDE OF CENTER HERTZBERG
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU FOR USING HIS RESOLUTION I
WANTED TO. MAKE A COUPLE OF
QUICK POINTS TO FIRST GIVE. A
KNOWLEDGE MEANT TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARCO FIREBALL PASSED
AWAY MANY YEARS AGO. BUT WHO
FOUGHT TIRELESSLY FOR AB FIVE
FORTY AND- THIS WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED BUT FOR HIM. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE BOARD OF
REGENTS. FOR VOLUNTARILY
ADOPTING THE STANDARD UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION OF CALIFORNIA THEY
DID NOT HAVE TO ABIDE BY THE
RULES UNDER. EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
UNLIKE THE STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM DID. BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOVERNED DIFFERENTLY IN OUR
CONSTITUTION. AND THROUGH A VERY
DELIBERATE- DISCUSSION INCLUDING
IT'S TIME TO THE GOVERNOR CRUZ
BUSTAMANTE AND OTHERS- WE
ADOPTED. A THESE REQUIREMENTS
AND SO I THINK IT'S RELATION YOU
RECEIVE CALIFORNIA I WANT TO
JUST MAKE SURE IS WE THE
KNOWLEDGE THESE MAGNET GIVE
CREDIT TO THOSE. ON WHO OFTEN
MANY OF US DON'T KNOW TODAY BUT
WHO SHOULDERS ON HOME WHICH WE
STAND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REDUCING STRESS LUCIEN
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION EVENT ON THE
SIDE OF. NINETY NINE SERIAL
MOMENTS A LOT CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL OUR ROLE IN FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS BATES.
BAKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO CORTES I DALY I
THOUGHT I TORONTO. EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO HI FURTADO I
JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA I LIMON I MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. MAN I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN I TROUBLED HI PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER I WILK. PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS. EIGHT BORDERS CABALLERO
THE ROSSUM GROVE JONES MELENDEZ
AMBERG WILK. DALY I TO KNOW.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS. EIGHT FOR JUST CABALLERO
THEY'RE ALSO ROAD JONES MELENDEZ
NUMBER WELL I IS TWENTY NINE
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES
NUMBERS REMOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM NINETEEN BY SENATOR GROW.
ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX
BY SENATOR GROWTH TO
WOMEN'S MILITARY HISTORY WEEK
SENATOR- THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT S. C. R.
EIGHTY SIX. A WHICH COMMEMORATES
MARCH FOURTEENTH TO MARCH
TWENTIETH AS WOMEN'S MILITARY
HISTORY WEEK CURRENTLY THERE ARE
OVER ONE POINT THREE MILLION.
AMAZING AND BRAVE WOMEN
DUTIFULLY SERVING IN THE ARMED
FORCES OF THE UNITED STATES AND
OVER NINE THOUSAND FEMALE TROOPS
HAVE EARNED A COMBAT ACTION
MEDAL OR BADGE. INCLUDING THOSE
IN IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN THIS
YEAR MARKS THE NINTH ANNIVERSARY
OF OVERTURNING THE NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR PENTAGON RULE THAT
ONCE RESTRICTED WOMEN FROM ALL
COMBAT RELATED ROLES INCLUDING
ARTILLERY ARMOR AND INFANTRY.
SINCE THEN WE SEE MORE WOMEN IN
LEADERSHIP AND FRONTLINE COMBAT
ROLES INCLUDING BRIGADIER
GENERAL LORI YEAGER A FORMER
BLACK HAWK HELICOPTER ASSUMING
COMMAND OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARDS. FORTIETH
INFANTRY DIVISION AND BECOMING
THE FIRST WOMAN TO COMMAND A
UNITED STATES ARMY INFANTRY
DIVISION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN WOMEN ARE NOW TRAINING
FOR THIS AND SERVING IN THE
INFANTRY ARMOR SHORT RANGE FIELD
ARTILLERY UNITS. AND OCCUPATIONS
IN A MINUTE AND THE NUMBER OF
THEM ARE RECEIVING THEIR RANGER
TABS AND IT THAT NUMBER INCLUDES
THOSE SERVING IN RANGERS GET
RECEIVING A RANGER TABS AND IS
THAT NUMBER IS CONTINUING TO
GROW. WOMEN AND ALL SERVICES ARE
ALSO NOW ELIGIBLE TO SERVE A
SPECIAL OPERATION FORCES.
DESPITE BIGGER YEARS THROUGHOUT
HISTORY WOMEN STILL SERVE THEIR
COUNTRY IN VARIOUS STRATEGIC
ROLES INCLUDING IN SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT DEBORAH SANSOM
DISGUISED HERSELF AS A MAN. TO
FLEE SERVE IN THE CONTINENTAL
ARMY DURING THE CIVIL WAR DOCTOR
MARY WALKER A PHYSICIAN BECAME
THE FIRST AND ONLY WOMAN EVER
AWARDED THE CONGRESSIONAL MEDAL
OF HONOR. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE SERGEANT LEANNE HESTER
BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN IN THE
UNITED STATES ARMY TO EARN A
SILVER STAR FOR DIRECT CONTACT
ACTION. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT GENERAL AN E. DUNWOODY
DUNWOODY BECAME THE FIRST FEMALE
FOUR STAR GENERAL IN OUR U. S.
MILITARY HISTORY. AND JUST LAST
YEAR A TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
CALIFORNIA MARINE CORPORAL
JULIANA YOK OF IT BECAME THE
FIRST WOMAN TO GRADUATE. AT THE
HOW IT'S OF COURSE AND TO TAKE A
COMBAT ARTILLERY LEADERSHIP ROLE
. EVEN TODAY AS I STAND HERE AND
SPEAK ON THIS FLOOR BRAVE WOMEN
VETERANS CONTINUE TO MAKE
HISTORY LIKE WHEN SOME SEARS THE
FIRST WOMAN TO SERVE AS
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA
AND ALSO THE FIRST WOMAN OF
COLOR IN FIRST JAMAICAN BORN
AMERICAN CITIZEN. ELECTED TO
STATEWIDE OFFICE IN VIRGINIA. AS
THE FIRST FEMALE VETERAN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
IT'S MY DISTINCT HONOR TO
PRESENT S. C. R. EIGHTY SIX
ALONG WITH TWO OTHER FEMALE
VETERANS THAT SIT ON THIS FLOOR
WITH ME. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON SENATOR EGGMAN AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM DOWN SOUTH
SENATOR MELENDEZ I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN RECOGNIZING WOMEN'S
HISTORY WEEK IN HONORING OUR
WOMEN WARRIORS. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I RISE
AS THE CHAIR OF THE MILITARY
VETERANS COMMITTEE AND I'M SO
HONORED. TO SERVE WITH THESE
PROUD WOMEN VETERANS ON THE
COMMITTEE. AND I'M ALSO HERE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT IT IS
SO TRUE THAT IN TODAY'S WORLD
WOMEN HAVE MADE SUCH AN
IMPRESSION- ON ALL OF US IN THE
MILITARY ALL WHO HAVE SERVED ALL
BRANCHES OF SERVICE. AND AS WAS
POINTED OUT BUT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BAKERSFIELD THAT WOMEN
RANGERS WOMEN PARATROOPERS WOMEN
IN COMBAT ORGANIZATIONS-
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
ARMY IN ALL BRANCHES. THEY HAVE
GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND THE CALL
OF DUTY AS YOU'VE HEARD I'D LIKE
TO POINT OUT MY OWN DAUGHTER IN
LAW TIFFANY ARCHULETA A
PARATROOPER. WHO SERVED IN IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN A MOTHER IT IS
AMAZING WHAT THE WOMEN OF TODAY
HAVE DONE IN THE MILITARY AND
WHAT THEY'VE DONE FOR
LEADERSHIP. AND SPEAKING OF
LEADERSHIP AT WEST POINT IN
ITSELF MORE WOMEN HAVE ACHIEVED
THOSE LEADERSHIP ROLES THAN ANY
OTHER TIME IN HISTORY AND
THEY'RE DOING IT WELL AND GOING
ON TO HIGHER RANKS. SO I
ACKNOWLEDGE- AGAIN ONCE AGAIN-
MY COLLEAGUES FROM BAKERSFIELD
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE THE
ARMED FORCES BUT IN PARTICULAR
MARCH WARRIOR MONTHS FOR OUR
WOMEN. AND I URGE AND I BOUGHT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
EGGMAN. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A
OF THIS BILL BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM KERN COUNTY I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IN THE
KNOWLEDGE IN THE VETERANS THAT
STAND ON THIS FLOOR WHO ARE
WOMEN AND ALSO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE NOTE AS THE- VICE CHAIR OF
THE LGBT CAUCUS WHICH ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE DR RACHEL LEVINE WHO
IS A FOUR STAR ADMIRAL. AND OUR
ASSISTANT. PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER- AND NOW WE ARE VERY
PROUD OF HER IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
S. C. R. EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER WINNER. THANK YOU I WANT
TO JUST REITERATE THE COMMENTS
OF THE SENATOR FROM. OFTEN
STOCKTON AND REALLY PRAISE- ALL-
WOMEN WHO WERE IN THE MILITARY I
INCLUDING- WOMEN AND THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND PARTICULARLY. A
TRANS WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN A
POLITICAL FOOTBALL- IN TERMS OF-
POLITICS THE MILITARY- AND THEY
STAND UP FOR OUR COUNTRY TO AND-
WE NEED TO IMPRESS ALL WOMEN.
WHO ARE SERVING IN THE MILITARY
THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE- ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THIS AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE
THIS MOMENT TO RE ITERATE WHAT'S
BEEN SAID ON THE FLOOR BUT
PARTICULARLY THANK THE WOMEN ON
THIS FLOOR FOR THEIR SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY ARE THE THREE WOMEN
THAT SERVE HERE WITH US- WE
FOREVER GRATEFUL AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH ARE YOU MEAN A LOT TO ME
AND YOUR SERVICE TO THIS COUNTRY
MEANS A LOT TO ALL OF US
COLLECTIVELY SOPINKA. OUR
NUMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION. OUR DEBATE
HERE IN CHINO AND SENATOR OVER
TO LIKE CLOSE. THIS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE SIR. MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON. THIS ITEM. HEARING C. NINE
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEASURE MEMBERS
BEFORE WE MOVE ON WE HAVE SOME
GUESTS WE WANT TO RECOGNIZED
TODAY IN THE GALLERY. FIRST WE
HAVE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR ALLAN
. BOSS WORLD CALL FROM THE US
COMMISSION ON CHINA HE'S JOINED
HERE TODAY BY HIS WIFE JANE. ARE
BOTH THE VISITING FROM TEXAS AS
WELL AS I DON'T HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
WELCOME YOU TODAY. NEXT WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE RIALTO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND-
THEREFORE- FROM THE DIP-
NUTRITION SERVICE DEPARTMENT
THERE IN THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR LEVIN IT'S OUR-
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE SAY
WELCOME. AND I'M ALSO GOING TO-
WE HAVE SOME FUTURE FARMERS OF
AMERICA UP IN THE GALLERY. FOR
H. COME ON STAND UP WE WANT TO
WELCOME YOU TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR GREAT WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING. A. J. HEY THANK YOU
WELCOME NOW IT'S TIME FOR
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT CENTRAL
MALL FOR WHAT PURPOSE THANK YOU
I MOVED FOR RECONSIDERATION ON
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN S. J. R.
NINETY. X. SHARE OUR NINE NINE
NINE OR NINE RESCUE CAREER
CONSIDERATIONS ARE ANY OBJECTION
- FOR RECONSIDERATION GROUP ON-
AS J. R. NINE. HEARING SEEING ON
RECONSIDERATION TO GRANITE ALL
EYES THIRTY SIX KNOWS IT ZERO.
BUT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AGAIN ON FILE ITEM SIXTY.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS. EIGHT BAKER I PORCHES BRADFORD
I HAVE ITEM CORTEZ HI DALLY.
DODD FIVE TORONTO EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I WROTE.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO I FURTADO I
JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA I LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ. MANY AYE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I CHOI BOGUE I PAN. I
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE HOMBURG
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER I WILL. MECSEK MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL OUT TO MEMBERS. ATKINS
BATES GORGEOUS CABALLERO SALLY
ROSSUM GROVE JONES MELENDEZ
AMBERG WILK. HIS TWENTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MEMBERS THIS TIME FOR
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THIS TIME-
HUESO ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THE SUN. YES
THE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS UTILITY WILL
BE. MEANING FIFTEEN MINUTES
AFTER THE ADJOURNMENT OF SENATE
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY TELECOM.
OKAY YEAH COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMMUNICATIONS- WILL BE MEETING
AT THREE O'CLOCK HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS THREE O'CLOCK
SENATE CHAMBERS. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WERE RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS NOW IS
THE TIME FOR A GERM THAT IN
MEMORY WE HAVE FIVE THIS
AFTERNOON FIRST UP IS SENATOR
BACKER. WE ASK THAT YOU REMAIN
IN YOUR SEATS IF POSSIBLE AND-
PROVIDE TYPE OF ATTENTION NEEDED
HERE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE IN TURN IN MEMORY OF.
TOUCH JANA PETS ABBAS AND HER
CHILDREN POLICE AND AKITA. THE
NEWS OF THE DEATH OF TOTS JANA
AND HER CHILDREN AND DAY A FRONT
PAGE NEW YORK TIMES PHOTO OF THE
SLAIN FAMILY. RESONATED AROUND
THE WORLD. AS THEY WERE KILLED
TRYING TO JUST CROSSING A
BRIDGE- EVACUATING UKRAINIAN
CITY OF URBAN ON MARCH SIXTH.
I'LL TOUCH ON A WORKED FOR
COMPANY MY DISTRICT S. C.
RANKINGS. AS ITS CHIEF
ACCOUNTANT. THE MAJORITY OF
EMPLOYEES OF THIS POWER TO BASED
A TECH COMPANY WERE YOU CRANIUM
. BECAUSE HER EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
SON NIKITA. I WAS UNABLE TO
LEAVE THE COUNTRY UNDER MARTIAL
LAW SHE'S DECIDED TO STAY IN HER
HOME TOWN OF URBAN WHEN THE
RUSSIAN INVASION BEGAN. WHEN A
BOMB HIT THEIR APARTMENT
BUILDING THEY DECIDED TO FLEE.
CROSSING THE BRIDGE ONLY TO BE
CAUGHT IN SHOWING FROM RUSSIAN
FORCES THAT HAS BESIEGED SO MANY
UKRAINIAN CITIES. TOUCH ON HIS
COLLEAGUES AT S. C. RANKINGS
DESCRIBED AS BRIGHT. WITTY AND
DETERMINED. S. THAT WE TURN
TODAY MEMORY OF TATIANA. NIKITA
AND LEASE THE FAMILY THAT WAS
HALFWAY AROUND THE WORLD BUT IT
TIES RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BRAVE VICTIMS OF AN UNPROVOKED
WAR. THAT HAS CLAIMED THE LIVES
OF HUNDREDS OF CIVILIANS LIKE
THE PETABYTES FAMILY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I ASK THAT YOU BRING
THE NAME FOR TO CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE YOUR BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. NEXT UP
WE HAVE CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO YOU INTERNET MEMORY ON
BEHALF OF BEVERLY FITCH MCCARTHY
WHO IS A LOCAL ICON IN THE
STOCKTON COMMUNITY- WELL BORN IN
SAINT LOUIS IN NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE. SHE FOUND HER WAY TO
CALIFORNIA. AND ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
BERKELEY- ED WAS WAS WHERE SHE
WENT TO SCHOOL AND FOUND HERSELF
TO BE THEPRESIDENT OF THE-
WOMEN'S SOCIETY. THERE WERE THAT
WAS THE STUDENT BODY AT THE TIME
APPARENTLY THEY WERE MEN'S AND
WOMEN'S THAT WERE SEPARATE.
AMONG HER FIRST ACTIONS- HAS A-
IS IT DEVELOPING FEMINIST WAS TO
SAY THAT THE WOMEN'S AND MEN'S.
CHEERING SECTION SHOULD BE EQUAL%
AT THE TIME THE WOMAN WERE GIVEN
TERRIBLE SEATS AND THE MEN WERE
GIVEN THE GOOD SEATS AND THEN
ALLOWED TO THROW THINGS DOWN. ON
THE WOMEN AND SO THAT WAS HER
FIRST ENTRY INTO. THE ISSUES
AROUND EQUALITY. AS IT RELATES
TO GENDER- SHE CONTINUED HER
LIFELONG WORK IN AND STOCKTON
GOT INVOLVED WITH. A AND CREATED
THE- SAYS A COMMISSION ON WOMEN-
SHE GOT INVOLVED WITH THE-
AMERICAN. UNIVERSITY OF WOMEN.
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
STARTED THE SUSAN B. ANTHONY. A
FOUNDATION AND WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST PEOPLE TO. WIN THAT- HE
WAS AN ACTIVIST AS LONG AS I
KNEW HER SHE- WAS ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD- WAS FINISHED HER CAREER
BUT ALSO. RAN AND SERVED ON THE
CITY COUNCIL ONE OF THE FIRST
WOMEN TO SERVE. AND AT THE TIME
FOR WOMEN BROWN AND SERVED AT
THE SAME TIME WHICH AT THAT TIME
WAS. A REALLY UNTHINKABLE- IS
SHE NEVER STOPPED BEING INVOLVED
SHE LOVED THE SYMPHONY WAS A
PRESIDENT OF THE SYMPHONY FOR
YEARS. WAS A PRESIDENT OF THAT
HI CAN MUSEUM IN STOCKTON FOR
YEARS- AND ANYTHING THAT WAS OF
A SPECIFIC NATURE. BEVY FITCH
MCCARTY WAS AT THE FOREFRONT OF
OUR- OF IT. IF DIED AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY EIGHT. LEAVING BEHIND
TWO CHILDREN FOUR STEPCHILDREN
NUMEROUS. GRANDCHILDREN AND UP
UNTIL JUST ABOUT BEFORE SHE DIED
SHE REMAINED INVOLVED AND ALWAYS
TRYING TO PUSH FOR MORE EQUALITY
AND TO FINALLY GET THE WOMEN'S.
RIGHTS AMENDMENT PASSED AND AS
WE KNOW THAT IS FINDING WORKING
ITS WAY TO FRUITION. SO I ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME IN THE MORALISING
BEVERLY FITCH MCCARTHY. OF
STOCKTON THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
ASK THAT YOU BRING THE NAME FOR
TO. MISS FITCH MCCARTY CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. NEXT UP
WE HAVE SENATOR COM LONGER.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY
OF NONI OLABISI WHO PASSED AWAY
ON MARCH FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SHE WAS SIXTY SEVEN YEARS OLD.
NONI OLABISI WAS BORN IN SAINT
LOUIS MISSOURI IN NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR BUT LEFT SHORTLY AFTER HER
MOTHER DIED. WHEN SHE WAS FOR
HER FATHER TOOK ALL THE B. C.
HER SISTER AND BROTHER TO
ARKANSAS WHERE THEY LIVED FOR
FIVE YEARS BEFORE RELOCATING TO
LOS ANGELES ALONG WITH A WOMAN
ALL OF BC'S FATHER HAD MARRIED.
WHO HAD FIVE CHILDREN OF HER OWN
. KNOWING HE WAS A SELF TAUGHT
LOS ANGELES ARTIST AND MURALIST
. NO NEEDS ARTWORK FOCUSED ON
THEMES ROOTED IN BLACK HISTORY
AND SOCIAL ISSUES. I HER MURALS
DEPICT THE ENDURANCE OF SPIRIT
MAINTAINED BY BLACKS BORN IN
AMERICA AND SPEAKS TO THE NEED
TO CONTINUE THE PERSEVERANCE FOR
JUSTICE AND EQUALITY. AMONG NO
KNEES MANY LARGE SCALE MURALS IS
FREEDOM WON'T WAIT. IN THE
THIRTIETH DISTRICT WHICH SHOWS A
NUMBER OF BLACK FIGURES CRYING
OUT FOR WINCING IN PAIN NO HE
MADE IT IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO
ON THE SIDE OF A SOUTH CENTRAL
BARBER SHOP WHERE SHE SOMETIMES
CUT HAIR. AFTER THE COMMUNITY
UPRISING THAT FOLLOWED 
ACQUITTAL OF POLICE OFFICERS
VIDEOTAPING VIDEOTAPED BEATING
RODNEY KING. NO NEWS WORK SPANS
OVER THIRTY YEARS AND SHE HAS
RECEIVED MANY AWARDS AND
RECOGNITION FOR HER ARTWORK
KNOWING HE WAS AWARDED THE
COVETED CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION VISUAL ARTIST
FELLOWSHIP. DOCUMENTARY OF LOS
ANGELES'S BLACK FRIDAY SHE
BROUGHT TO HER PRACTICE A DEEPLY
SPIRITUAL APPROACH THROUGH WHICH
SHE MANIFESTS HER INCREDIBLE
DESIGNS. NONI IS ALSO KNOWN FOR
SOME OF HER OTHER MURALS. TO
PROTECT AND SERVE RESURRECTION
IT TAKES A VILLAGE TO RAISE A
CHILD AND TRUMPET FOR THE PEOPLE
AND MANY OF THESE ARE IN THE
THIRTY EIGHTH AND IF YOU ARE
EVER IN THE DISTRICT. I REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DRIVE AROUND-
AND YOU WILL JUST BE SURPRISED
WHEN YOU TURN A CORNER OFF OF
JEFFERSON AND ELEVEN FOR EXAMPLE
AND SEE ONE OF HER ARTWORKS ONE
OF HER MURALS. AS AN ARTIST
KNOWN HE SAID THE INTENTION IS
TO CREATE ARTWORK THAT SPEAKS TO
THE HEART AND SOUL OF MANKIND.
INVOKING SELF EXAMINATION I
BELIEVE MY ART PROVIDES A
JOURNEY THAT LEADS US ALL TO THE
DISCOVERY OF THE ONE THING WE
ALL HAVE IN COMMON. LIGHT THE
LIGHT UNITES US ALL TO THE
REALIZATION THAT WE ARE ALL
RELATED. YOU KNOW I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF MEETING NONI OLABISI
WHEN I WORKED FOR AT SPARK UNDER
JUDY BACA THE SOCIAL PUBLIC ART
RESOURCE CENTER AND I WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR. A RESTORATION
PROJECT IN EACH OF THE CITY
COUNCIL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
CITY. AND WE- RENOVATED
RESURRECTED A COUPLE OF- I'VE
HEARD AND HAD HER INVOLVED IN IT
AND SHE WORKED WITH ANOTHER
ARTIST ALMA LOPEZ. AND THEY DID
MUCH OF THEIR ART WORK TOGETHER
IN COLLABORATION IN SOUTH LA AND
NONI WAS THIS AMAZING BRIGHT
LIGHT OF- INSPIRATION OF
RESILIENCE EFFORT AT FORTITUDE
SHE WAS SO EVEN. AND SHE REALLY
EXEMPLIFIED WHAT IT MEANS TO
pSURVIVED BY HER SON RENDEZ
SPEARS AND HER GRANDSON YUBARI
BEERS SHE WAS A TEACHER A MENTOR
AND HER CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
LEGACY OF MURAL ART CANNOT BE
MEASURED. THERE WILL BE A PUBLIC
MEMORIAL SCHEDULED FOR APRIL.
AND I ASK THAT WE RESPECTFULLY%
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER CAMARGO WE ARE
SAID TO BRING THE NAME FOR IT SO
SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
MELINDA US. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES IN GERMAN I
RISE TODAY IN THE JOURNAL MEMORY
RICHARD DALY CRUZ. I CAN SAID
YOUR MIND BORN IN LOS ANGELES TO
JENNY AND JOSE DELA CRUZ HE GREW
UP IN FONTANA WHERE HE LIVED
UNTIL HE MARRIED HIS WIFE OF
FORTY ONE YEARS DELIA. THE
COUPLE MOVED TO RIVERSIDE COUNTY
IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES AND BEGAN
THEIR FAMILY. WHICH INCLUDES
EIGHT CHILDREN ELISABETH RICHARD
JUNIOR HAY SEUSS ADRIAAN OCARINA
AT MICHAEL ANTHONY. AND HIS
DAUGHTER JENNY WHO PRECEDED HIM
IN DEATH. HIS WIFE'S OCCUPATION
WAS AS A CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER ANY WORK FOR VERY
CITIES- IN THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE
AND HE LOVED HIS JOB HE LOVED IT
SO MUCH THAT HE DID IT FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE HE CO FOUNDED
OPERATIONS SILVER STAR. HE ALONG
WITH HIS WIFE BEGIN THE
ORGANIZATION AFTER ONE OF THEIR
SONS HAD BEEN SEVERELY INJURED
WHILE SERVING OUR COUNTRY IN
IRAQ HE DEDICATED ALL IN HIS
RETIREMENT YEARS TO SERVING
THOSE WHO SERVED US. UP UNTIL
THE VERY LAST DAYS OF HIS LIFE
EVEN WHILE HE WAS IN THE
HOSPITAL HE WAS STILL TAKING
PHONE CALLS FROM VETERAN TO
REQUESTING ASSISTANCE. AND THE
RICHARD NEVER SERVED OUR COUNTRY
WEARING THE UNIFORM HIMSELF HE
MOST CERTAINLY SERVED OUR
COUNTRY WELL BY ASSISTING OUR
COUNTRY'S VETERANS AND I ASKED
TEACHER IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MELENDEZ
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO
HE MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY I. ASKED
THAT WE TURN IN MEMORY YOU TO
NOT ONLY A CONSTITUENT. BUT A
FRIEND A MENTOR A FATHER FIGURE
TO NOT ONLY ME BUT TO SO MANY OF
US. AS WE- WATCH AND ENJOY THE
IN SITU A BASKETBALL TOURNAMENT
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR THE
NEXT TWO WEEKS. I ASK THAT YOU
KNOW THE NAME OF BOOKER TURNER.
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
OFFICIAL WEST OF THE MISSISSIPPI
. TO WORK A AND C. TO A
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN OFFICER TO LEAD
AN ALL BLACK CREW AT A PACKED IN
GAME THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
BECOME SUPERVISOR OF OFFICIALS
OF A MAJOR CONFERENCE. BOOKER
TURNER AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS
READ BY HIS WIFE AND MANY OF HIS
FRIENDS BUT TO PEOPLE LIKE
MYSELF FRIENDS OF HIS SON AND
DAUGHTER. DANNY AND RONNIE YOU
SIMPLY KNOWN AS POP. HE WAS BORN
IN HOPE ARKANSAS AND MOVED TO
LOS ANGELES WHEN HE WAS TEN
YEARS OLD. HE WAS A PROUD
GRADUATE OF ROOSEVELT HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE HE WENT BACK
REGULARLY TO MENTOR MANY OF THE
YOUNG STUDENTS THEY'RE NOT ONLY
THE ATHLETES WITH STUDENTS AS A
WHOLE. MISTER TURNER LISTED IN
THE UNITED STATES ARMY AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL AND HE WAS STATIONED
IN GERMANY AND WHILE THERE. HE
CONTINUED HIS LOVE FOR SPORTS BY
PLAYING FOOTBALL. BASEBALL AND
RUNNING TRACK. ON HIS RETURN TO
THE STATES MISTER TURNER
CONTINUE PLAYING COMPETITIVE
SPORTS UNTIL LIGHT NEAR INJURY
INJURY SLOWED HIM DOWN. THIS
ALLOWED HIM TO RECOGNIZE GOD'S
CALLING FOR HIS LIFE TO MENTOR
YOUTH. AS A WAY TO STAY
CONNECTED TO THE SPORT THAT HE
LOVED HE STARTED OFFICIATING
BASKETBALL IN INNER CITY PARKS
AS A WAY TO CONNECT WITH KIDS
WHO HAD A SIMILAR BACKGROUND AS
HIS. HE POURED HIS HEART AND
SOUL INTO THE GAME AND QUICKLY
MOVED UP THE RANKS TO WORK HIGH
SCHOOL COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
MAJOR UNIVERSITIES. WHEN HE
WALKED ON THE FLOOR HE EXUDED
CONFIDENCE OF A MAN THAT WAS
GOING TO ALWAYS GIVE HIS BEST.
HE WAS. STRIVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
HE SHOWED UP AT EVERY GAME IN A
SUIT. WELL PRESSED A T<c.cyan> ISSUES</c>
POLISHED IN HIS NAILS MANICURED
ON AND OFF THE COURT FOR STUDENT
ATHLETES. HIS LOVE THE GAME AND
HIS ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
YOUNG PLAYERS WITH SIMILAR
BACKGROUNDS GAVE HIM A
CONNECTION THAT WENT. ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE BASKETBALL COURT.
MANY SAID HIS BASKETBALL IQ
WHAT'S THE BEST WITHOUT QUESTION
. MISTER TURNER REACHED MANY
MILESTONES IN HIS CAREER WORKING
ALL THE TOP CONFERENCES ALL THE
TOP GAMES TRAVELING TO MANY
FOREIGN COUNTRIES THE WORD GAMES
WORKING IN C. TO A BASKETBALL
TOURNAMENT GAMES FOR TWENTY
CONSECUTIVE YEARS. INCLUDING
MANY REGIONAL FINALS SIX FINAL
FOURS AND REACHING THE PINNACLE
OF COLLEGE SPORTS WORKING THREE
NC TWO EIGHT CHAMPIONSHIP GAMES
MANY FEEL HE CALLED WHAT WAS
CONSIDERED THE BEST.
CHAMPIONSHIP FINAL HOUSTON
AGAINST GEORGETOWN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR FIVE SELAMA JAM
AGAINST GEORGETOWN AKEEM
OLAJUWON. AND PATRICK EWING ON
THE COURT IT WAS SAID THAT YOU
EITHER LOVE THEM OR HATE YOU
KNOW ONE THING FOR SURE YOU
RESPECTED HIM. HIS IMPACT ON THE
GAME IS RECOGNIZED IN A WART
THIS NAMED AFTER HIM. THE BOOKER
TURNER AWARD WHICH IS AWARDED
EVERY YEAR IN THE TWELFTH IN THE
PAC TWELVE TO THE REFEREE
DISPLAYS SPIRIT AND COURAGE. HE
WAS SOLELY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DIVERSITY IN THE LEAGUE SO MUCH
SO. THAT WHEN HE WAS A
SUPERVISOR OF THE PAC TWELVE IT
HE'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FIRST
FEMALE. A REFEREE TO CALL EIGHT
NC I MEAN OUR NBA FINAL FORMER
NBA REFEREE VIOLET PALMER WHO
GREW UP IN COMPTON AND WAS A
MENTEE OF BOOKER TURNER. WHEN
MICHAEL JORDAN INFORMER YOU SEE
S. U. S. C. AND A WASHING STATE
COACH GEORGE RAVELING HIT THEIR
CAMP WHOSE ONLY ONE REFEREE THAT
THEY HAND PICKED TO BE DIRECTOR
OF OFFICIALS FOR BEST CAMP
BECAUSE THEY SAID. THE BEST
NEEDED THE GREATEST. MISTER
TURNER HAD MANY PROFESSIONAL
ACCOMPLISHMENT BUT HE'S
CONSIDERED HIS FAMILY HIS
GREATEST ACCOMPLISHMENT. MISTER
TURNER WAS MARRIED TO HIS LOVING
WIFE BETTY BETTER KNOWN AS PUNCH
FOR SIXTY SIX YEARS. HE WAS A
COMPASSIONATE LOVING FATHER
DEDICATED TO WORKING HARD TO
ENSURE HIS Q. AS DANNY IRANI
WHAT THEY NEEDED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL SO MUCH SO THAT HE
PASSED ON THREE. INVITATIONS TO
JOIN THE NBA BECAUSE HE FELT IT
WOULD TAKE HIM AWAY FROM HIS
FAMILY FOR FAR TOO LONG ANY
STATE COACHING ANY REFEREEING
COLLEGE SPORTS. ALWAYS A
VISIONARY BOOKER WORKED HARD. AT
HEARING HIS KNOWLEDGE INTO THE
NEXT GENERATION OF YOUNG MAN. I
REMEMBER THE LIKES OF BYRON
SCOTT AND MARKETS JOHN SAID IN
RALEIGH HOW MOUNTAIN ALL WERE
REGULARS AT ETERNAL HOME HE
MENTORED NUMEROUS- PLEASE BILL
WALTON WAS A BIG FAN OF THIS. I
AND HIS HE IS KNOWN AS BEING THE
FIRST IT MIGHT BE FOLKLORE THE
CALL A TECHNICAL. ON JOHN
WOODEN. BUT HE DEFINITELY CALL
THE TECHNICAL. JOHN WHAT. BOOKER
WOULD BEAM WITH PRIDE KNOWING
THAT HIS GRANDSON'S A MILITARY
VETERAN AND THREE COLLEGE
GRADUATES WERE PREPARED FOR
GREAT GREATNESS. HIS GRANDSON
ANDREW VICTOR. R. CAMERON AND
DONOVAN. HE WAS WELL KNOWN FOR
HIS CONFIDENCE. HE WAS A I MEAN
AS A CONFIDENT I SHOULD SAID
ADVISER AND A HERO TO MANY YOUNG
ADULTS THAT HE MEANT TOWARD. HIS
KIND SPIRIT AND CARING DEMEANOR
AND HIS DEDICATION TO BETTERING
THE LIVES OF THOSE AROUND HIM
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED. MANY
SAID HE LIVED LIFE ON HIS OWN
TERMS. BUT HE WOULD TELL YOU HE
LIVED LIFE BY THE RULES. AND
THAT YOU FIRST NEED TO KNOW THE
RULES IN ORDER TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF ALL. ON THE COURT AND IN LIFE
BOOKER TURNER KNEW THE RULES.
I'M BLESSED CALL HIM POPS. HE
HAD A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON MY
LIFE. HE IS SURVIVED AGAIN BY
HIS WIFE BETTY. THAT I AFFECTS
THE CALL MOM. MY BEST FRIEND HIS
SON RONNIE BOWL. HIS GRANDSONS
ANDREW. VICTOR DONOVAN IN
CAMERON IS GUARDADO TIFFANY
BALLARD DAVIS AND A HOST OF
RELATIVES NIECES AND NEPHEWS WHO
ALL AFFECTIONATE CAUGHT HIM POPS
AND HE WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY
HIS LOVING GARTER DANNY I HAVE
NO I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT THERE UP
AND HAVE A RIGHT NOW READY TO
WATCH THE NC TWO A. FINALS
TOGETHER AND RUTH AND RUTH AND
YELL AND HOLLER AND- POTHOLE A
LOT OF MESS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
BOOKER DID HE WAS AN- AMAZING
COOK. AGAIN AND M. PACKABLE
DRESSER. LOVED CARS I YOU WOULD
NEVER SEE A WITHOUT A BEAUTIFUL
NEW CAR. AND JUST A STRAIGHT
TALKER YOU COULDN'T ASK FOR A
BETTER HUMAN BEING AND I'M
HONORED TO CALL MY FAMILY FRIEND
AND OF AND I HAVE TO WEAR DURING
THE MEMORY OF BOOKER. RED TURNER
. THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO
YOU CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR BATES THE DESK
IS CLEAR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE AND WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
GENERAL MOTION WILL BE MADE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM.
HAVE A GREAT REST TODAY MEMBERS.